So bio degradation,
there's a lot of definitions out there.
A lot of them are sort of political and regulatory and in the details,
but the most basic definition of biotech decoration you'll see out there is
that,
you know,
the bio part means that there needs to be some sort of biological activity going
on and that there should be some kind of change taking place.
And that's really it.
And all the details are about what kind of biological organisms and then what
kind of changes are taking place.
So the most commonly accepted
definitions of vibe Degra biodegradability that you'll see in commercial
products,
like when something is advertised as being bio degradable,
there's often come from the Oec d guidelines and they have a couple of
categories.
There's ready biodegradability and ultimate biodegradability.
And you can see these are,
these are pretty complicated definition.
So the ready biodegradability test is you'll have some kind of organic chemical
that dissolves in water and do you set up a 28 day test and sometime during that
28 day test you have to either will not either you have to remove 70% of the
dissolved organic carbon and achieve a certain level of theoretical oxygen
demand or co two production within a 10 day window.
So cut all that.
So thinking about these different requirements,
if we think back to the early classes when we're talking about stoichiometry,
what,
why,
why would we be talking about oxygen demand and CO2 production?
What,
what's happening to the,
to the organic chemical.
So we have some generic carbon in there.
What's going on?
What's the reaction?
So what,
what's reacting?
Yeah.
So yeah,
some sort of oxygen and it can be Otu gas.
I mean biological organisms are very complicated.
There may be some sort of catalyst involved inside the cell,
inside the bacteria.
And then your product is c o two and so you can calculate it as we did earlier
in class based on how much carbon is in your compound.
What is the theoretical amount of oxygen that you would need and then what's the
theoretical amount of co two that you can produce.
So those numbers are very easy to come up with theoretically.
And then you basically sat the test to measure that.
And the reason why they're doing this,
this 10 day window in a 28 day test is you could imagine a couple of different
scenarios.
So if this is a time component,
and let's say this is co two production,
so if something is really quickly biodegradable and you know bacteria loves it,
you might expect something kind of like this.
So you get really rapid production of co two and then eventually it runs out of
the chemical,
right?
You could have something that looks like this,
that maybe the bacteria is not familiar with this substrate.
And then over time it adapts to it and then starts
consuming it.
And then you can also have situations where the bacteria just doesn't know what
to do with it at all.
And if you're lucky,
maybe you get five or 10%.
So something like this,
this could,
you could achieve your 60 70% biodegradation in a 10 day window and something
like this,
you know,
your 10 day window,
both of these are considered essentially readily biodegradable.
So in some 10 day period you're getting rid of virtually all of the,
the carbon
and then ultimate biodegradability is kind of a step down.
That just means that,
uh,
instead of a 10 day window,
you've done it in a 28 day window.
So it's not as fast,
but it still gets the job done.
And then the,
the level of complexity can get almost a arbitrarily
complex that,
uh,
thinking about different organisms that you might encounter in different
situations.
So,
um,
wastewater treatment,
bacteria versus soil,
bacteria,
aerobic versus anaerobic.
So this is,
uh,
an important consideration because we were just talking about c plus o going to
see o two is that aerobic or anaerobic?
So that's Arabic.
So under aerobic conditions you have your C's going to see oh two.
Um,
we have like an would be going to an x and s mean to sox and so on.
metals,
I'll just put m for metals are going to be going to
metal oxides and then under anaerobic conditions.
So there's no oxygen present.
You have reducing environment.
Does anybody know what,
what carbon's going to under reducing environments?
So where,
where would you encounter Arabic biodegradation like surface
and like moving water?
Um,
if you're,
depending on what type type of compost you're doing,
so compost where they're mixing it continuously.
How about anaerobic?
Where,
where,
where do we to peer about methane emissions and ammonia emissions?
Most landfills are packed so tightly that there's essentially no way for the
oxygen to penetrate down into where the organic stuff is.
And so the anaerobic bacteria thrive under those conditions.
So not everybody will choose to use OEC DEF OACD definitions.
There's also ISO methods,
EPA methods,
STM methods.
And there,
there are literally dozens if not hundreds of them.
And that basically just speaks to the complexity of bio degradation pathways
that um,
you know,
each organism is going to have its own enzymes,
its own catalysts,
and probably different intermediates.
So the,
the methods that go with actually tracking biodegradation are pretty labor
intensive.
So,
uh,
a lot of them have to do with measuring either your starting material directly
or measuring these different gases.
So that's what these,
uh,
this dissolved organic carbon doc die away.
That would be tracking disappearance of the carbon,
uh,
CO2 evolution o two consumption.
There's different gas detecting technologies.
And then to this point about like,
uh,
oxygen depleted water versus oxygen rich water.
There's all types of different matrices that you can look at.
So soil,
um,
different types of aqueous environments.
ANAEROBIC digesters are big one because a lot of people are setting up these bio
gas facilities where they're shoveling organic stuff into,
uh,
an,
an anaerobic reactor on purpose because they want to capture the methane gas.
And there,
there are tests where you can simulate composting at different temperatures.
So,
um,
in compost bacteria are used to having higher temperatures.
You have to model that.
And then there's processes where you might introduce some other chemical
techniques.
So helping the bio degradation along by using something like photochemistry if
the chemical reacts with,
with,
um,
with light or,
like UV radiation,
uh,
foot,
hydrolytic chemistry can also help these things along.
And that might help shorten some of these induction periods where the bacteria
may not know what to do with the chemical in the very beginning.
But if you're sort of pushing that process along through photo chemistry,
then you can get,
get it to look more like this rapid profile.